Okay. Does someone have another question?
Yes. We are real people.
Graham says asking a live question produced a weird effect
as by now we're very used to hearing recorded video.
We don't make mistakes on video.
I can also show you my arm is really not transparent.
I have to eat a lot of rice noodles to make it transparent for the recordings,
but normally it's not.
You were saying you had a question--Graham.
We can click on someone?
Well, you just have their name and you can see right here.
Go ahead, Graham.
Oh no, I said not a question.
Okay. Who has a question? >>I have a question.
Go ahead. John. Where are you from John? >>I'm from New York.
Hi, John from New York. What's the question.
It seems to me that all of the homework problems--
I mean, do they all count for equal points even though some of them are much harder than others.?
This is very true.
They question is does each homework question count the same
even though there's a big difference in how hard the questions are?
This is the way things are now that every question counts for 1 point,
and we don't have a way to give partial credit.
This is definitely a limitation of our grading system that we would--
there are questions that definitely involve a lot more work than others,
and there are questions that we would like to be able to give partial credit for.
That's probably something we'll be able to do in future offerings of the course.
At this point that's a limitation of the way grading works.
Every question is worth the same amount of points.
I encourage people not to get too caught up in the grading.
So definitely my hope is that for the harder questions that you feel like
you've accomplished something and learned a lot by doing it
even if it's only worth 1 point, or even worse, if it's worth 1 point,
but because of some quirk in the grading system or you forget to remove a stray print or something,
you don't get that point, try not to get too upset and frustrated by that.
The goal of the homeworks is really for you to learn from that.
Hopefully you feel that you've accomplished something and even if you didn't get the point
because the way it was graded, you know that you actually were on the right track
and understood the things that we wanted you to get out of that question.
Expanding on that question, since I did just kind of start today,
I was wondering if the due dates matters?
You should repeat that. >>The question is since Michelle is starting late if the due dates matter.
They do in the sense of the grades
that you get for the homework are based on the answers that you submit before the due date.
They don't matter other than that.
You can do the homeworks after the deadline.
If you submit them after the deadline, you see right away whether the answer is correct.
You can get all the same learning benefit out of the homeworks.
Also, you can still get a perfect score in the class even if you missed the homeworks,
both because one of the ways of grading now is just counting the exam.
Students who join the class late aren't able to get credit for the early homeworks,
but if they learn the material and do well on the exam
you still have a chance to get a perfect score in the class.
I hope students do value the grades they get on the homeworks,
but definitely if you are starting the class late, you can still do the homeworks,
still learn from them, and still have a chance to get a perfect score in the class.
Part of the reason to do that is it's a really good just keeping everyone together.
It'd be hard to hold a session like this if we had half our students on Unit 4
and a third on Unit 1, and another third on another unit.
That's a good point that there are online classes you can do complete at your own pace.
For many people that works well.
For the other people without having the pressure of a deadline and the community experience
of going through a course at the same time and being able to do something like we're doing now
with live office hours, you really miss that experience,
and it's much harder to keep up with the course if you don't have deadlines.
But we don't want people to feel like they'll drop out of the course
because you missed 1 deadline because you weren't able to get the grade on that homework.
Definitely, the deadlines, if they're helpful for you then take the deadline seriously,
but it's certainly not required to take the deadlines that seriously. >>Thank you.
There's a text question about using third-party libraries for web development.
Okay, so this is a text question for me.
This is also a good point, that our goal in this class is to teach computer science concepts,
using the goal of building a search engine as a vehicle for doing that.
If your real goal was just to build the best search engine you could
then you'd be much better off using existing libraries and putting them together
rather than learning how to build your own extracting a links function, say.
What we did in Unit 1.
It's definitely a trade-off, and the trade off we're making here is to learn computer science concepts.
If your goal was to just build a search engine as quickly as you could,
the way we're doing it in class would not be the best way to do that.
Someone asks, "Are there plans to robots.txt?"
This is a good question.
I hope you saw the interview with Anna Patterson at the end of Unit 3
where she talks about how important it is to be polite in a real web crawler.
Someone did ask on the forums what it means to be "polite."
How can a computer be polite to another computer.
Yes, and politeness is--I'm glad that Anna used the word "polite"
because it's not the normal word people would use,
but it's actually a good way to think about it that just like when people interact
you're not supposed to interrupt people or yell at them all the time. That's impolite to do that.
When computer interact with other computers, they're not people getting offended in the same way.
But if you do the kinds of things that are rude when people do them
they cause problems for the other computers.
So if you're sending requests as fast as you can at the same server
and trying to crawl that entire server and sending millions of requests to it
that's really rude. That's taking resources away from the server.
It costs money.
It's costing the server operator money, and it's preventing people that actually want to get
the content because they're looking for that page from getting it.
To be a good citizen on the web, if you're writing a web crawler, you have to follow rules
and limit the resources that you take from the servers that you're crawling.
Robots.text is a file that servers can put on the server that says,
"Here's rules about how you should crawl this server."
It might give a rate limit. It might say, "Don't crawl these pages."
It might say how often can you request-- >>Sometimes that's for privacy reasons.
Yeah, it could be for privacy. It could be for resource us.
It could be there are pages on the site that they don't want to end up in an index.
A well-behaved web crawler will always check this before requesting any other pages from the site.
For the crawler that we built in this class, we're not doing that,
and the reason we're not doing that is our goal is to make things as simple as possible
and to understand as much computer science.
The work of reading the robots.txt file, understanding what's in it,
regulating the crawler, well, that would be hundreds of lines of code.
The entire web crawler by the very end of this class will be less than 70 lines of code. >>70?
Our goal is to really make it so you understand everything that's going on in core web crawler,
and the search engine is all included in the 70 lines,
but not need to get into a lot of the details that if you were building
a real web crawler it'd be important to get into.
The good part of this is at least if you're running the code through our server,
you don't have to worry about politeness, because we're not actually allowing any of
the programs you submit to make arbitrary web requests.
All the reponses that you get are just for the test pages that we have cached the results for at our server.
When you submit code, even if it used get_page to request pages,
it's not actually sending out real web requests, so it's being polite. >>Yes.
Did we want take--does someone have a question they want to ask?
Yeah, does someone have a question whose is a non-typing question? >>Go for it.
No one. >>I have one.
Good. Well, we have another typed one.
We got what did the--that's an easy one.
Rishad wants to know where the name "Udacity" come from.
It has a couple different possibilities.
The most obvious is there is a word "audacity," which means boldness, daring,
and we removed the "a" from audacity to get Udacity.
We like it starting with a U because that sounds like a university.
The "-city" sort of also sounds like university, so that's where the name came from.
I know some people hate, some people like it. It's the name we're going to use.
I hope everyone comes to like it.